hey thank you for staying for the
section uh this talk is about the
addition function
and bounded depth circuits and uh this
is a joint work with c
chain and rocker video from columbia
so in the first part mentioned result
about the exponential weights in
monotone majority circuits
and in the second part a consequence for
ac 0.
so let's start uh recall that a boolean
function
f is a weighted threshold function
if there are integer or weights w1 to wm
and a threshold t
such that f of x is one if and only if
this weighted sum is at least t
and here is a picture this means that
there is some hyperplane that separates
the zero inputs from the one inputs of
the function
okay so this is a well-known definition
and it goes by different names such as
half spaces and linear threshold
functions etc
okay now you're also very familiar with
this uh if we compose many of these
threshold gates
then we arrive at threshold circuits and
uh
for this talk i'm gonna measure the size
of a threshold circuit as
the number of gates in the circuit and
layers is
what you are familiar with so this one
has a
size 10. so i don't care about the
weights inside each individual threshold
gate here okay
and uh you know that the threshold
circuits they are
one of the frontiers in complex theory
today uh
it's a simple model uh but uh the power
uh remains uh mysterious for us
for instance uh it's open if we can
solve let's say
direct dusty connectivity using constant
there polynomial size threshold circuits
however uh we have uh some
relative success in understanding the
role of large weights in the gates of
the circuits
okay so let me tell you um about it in a
second
so before let me just introduce the
following notation
i'm gonna use majority circuits for
exactly the same model
but here i care about the weights inside
each gate
okay so for instance if we have a
threshold gate like this
the weight of this gate is just the sum
of the absolute values
of the coefficients okay
so and we're going to measure the size
of the majority circuit by the total
weight in the circuit
okay so uh results from the 90s
show that if you start with these
threshold gates and they have bounded
depth
and a polynomial number of gates then we
can simulate them
with uh bounded depth majority circuits
of polynomial size
so in other words we can reduce uh the
exponential weights
to polynomial weights okay and the depth
is uh blows up by some constant
and subsequent work has shown that
actually in this simulation we can start
with that d threshold circuits
and get that d plus one majority
circuits okay
this was a non-constructive proof and uh
next year goldman karpinski gave a
constructive simulation for this
reduction
and after this other works have
simplified or improved size parameters
in this reduction
now goldman and karpinski back in 93
they observed the following
if the original threshold circuit is
monotone which means that
the weights are positive inside each
gate then
this simulation that reduces the weight
from exponential to polynomial
will produce uh majority circuits with
negative weights
okay and they asked is there a monotone
transformation
or this introduction of negative weight
uh this is inherent in this
transformation
uh so what was known about this question
in 92 hofmeister showed the following
there is just a single monotone
threshold gate
with large weights such that you cannot
simulate with two layers
of monotone majorities okay if you want
to have a simulation like this
then you need the weights to be a two to
the square root of n
and uh the function used by hofmeister
is actually computed
by depth 3 monotone majority circuits
so uh in trying to understand this
question as by goldman karpinski
one of our main difficulties was really
figuring out in
which direction it went to so it wasn't
clear for us before we started this
project it was a source of difficulty
we looked at some of the proofs and
tried to make the monotone and we
couldn't do it
and eventually we arrived at a solution
to the problem
and we showed the following there is no
efficient monotone simulation in
any fixed depth d okay so in other words
uh there is a single monotone threshold
gate with exponential weights
but if you only want to use a constant
number of monotone majorities
constant number of layers then they need
to have exponentially large weights
and the function we use is an extension
of the function used by hofmeister
so we call it u sub dn and
it means the following the input for
this function is
d natural numbers they are represented
in binary and
it has any bits and we want to check if
the sum of these numbers is at least 2
to the n
and addition is a highly non-monotone
function but since here we are checking
if it's at least 2 to the n
this this definition gives a monotone
function okay
so here's a picture representing this
function we have these
d rows each one containing one of the
numbers and we have the n columns
so we're gonna add an app and check if
this addition produced some carry bit
okay so this is the most significant bit
and here's lecture to the end
and of course this uh can be represented
by
a single threshold gate which just
converts the binary numbers to decimal
and check if it's to the end
so this is like a very simple threshold
circuit
and uh formally we've established the
following theorem
we showed that any depth d monotone
majority circuit
computing u d sub n summing the numbers
must have size 2 to the n to the one
over d
okay
and so therefore the answer to their
question is no
you cannot have the monotone simulation
and you may ask if this lower bound for
this function is optimal and this is a
second result we have in this
work which is there is a matching upper
bound it's it's not obvious
but you can construct such monotone
circuits with the
this way okay so i won't have time to
discuss the proof but this is why this
is here just to say that it's a proof by
induction
so uh what we do is uh
we define some pairs of distributions
over the zero inputs and the one inputs
so
one inputs these are going to be numbers
with some at least two then lower inputs
some less than two to the n
and we show that these two distributions
they are uh
very hard for small depth circuits
so for instance this pair here is going
to be very hard for
that to monotone majority circuits and
then
we're going to do something and we're
going to create new a pair of
distributions
which are hard now for depth 3 circuits
and so on but in this process we need to
to introduce pairs of pairs of
distributions for some technical reasons
i want to be able to cover in this stuff
okay so yeah there is an inductive lemma
showing that
um these distributions they are hard for
like
larger depth and that each one is
constructed from the previous pairs
okay and we need to explore and disprove
monotonicity and low weights in a
crucial way
okay so now and in the second part of
the talk i'll show an application of
this lower bound
in the context of monotonicity and ac
zero complexity
okay so before let's just review uh this
concept of monotonicities for boolean
functions
so uh first we all know how to define
monotone functions
these are functions where if you flip
from a zero to one an input bit
then then the output bit can only go
from zero to one
and this is uh we can view this as a
semantic definition of this object which
is the boolean function
and uh on the other hand we have the
definition of a monotone circuits
which uh is a form of representing
monotone functions
right and we know that the class of
functions computed like monotone
circuits
is precisely the class of monotone
functions okay
but although we have this equivalence it
doesn't mean that
the complexity is preserved in this
equivalence okay so it's not necessarily
true that
if you start with a fixed monotone
function and the best circuit for that
monotone function
is a monotone circle okay
and i time gravity in 87 they were
interested in this kind of question
motivated by
something in finite modal theory which i
want to mention now
and they established the following
stronger result which was enough for
them
they proved that there exists a monotone
function g
from n bits to bit such that this
function is an ac
zero so we have a very shallow and uh
polynomial size circuits for it but now
if you force these ac zero circles to be
monotone
then you need the super polynomial size
okay so intuitively this means that
negations can speed up the boundary
depth computation of monotone functions
okay and if we inspect the proof
it turns out that this function gn is
computed by monotonic zero circuits of
quasi-polynomial size
so if you uh so
their approach using this function
cannot give you a stronger separation
than quasi polynomial
this brings us to a very natural
question is there an exponentially speed
up in bounded zap
okay so if we use cancellations or
negations can we
compute monotone functions much faster
and the analogous question for arbitrary
circuits that
it was answered positively by tardos in
88.
so in the case that there is no bounds
on the depth of the circuits we know
that this is true
negations can give you an exponential
speed
okay so our second result is uh
answering the
that question so indeed uh
there is a monotone function on n bits
such that
this function is an ac0 and in fact it
is computed by only three layers
and this monotone function requires
depth d monotone majority circuits of
size
roughly two to the n to the one over d
so compared to uh the i digrammed
theorem
this result gives an exponential
separation instead of causing polynomial
and our hardness is uh against majority
gates instead of and or gates
so it's stronger in distant two senses
okay and how do we prove this result
well we had this monotone function which
is u sub the n
and we already know this function is
hard for majority circuit of bounded
depth
and to get this theorem what we do is we
just mention the upper bound for this
function
and you can actually compute it for
small values of k in depth 3.
so it means that even if you have only
three layers of computation if you use
negations you can have the exponentially
speed up
for monotone functions
okay so uh let me just now conclude uh
what we have shown is that the
addition function is a monotone function
but monotone bonded depth circuits for
this function they are exponentially
weaker
than general circuits so it's a very
natural function for which this happens
but on the other hand there are other
monotone functions that are very natural
such that there's the connectivity
problem with bounded distance
uh we know now that uh
for this function monotone boundary
depth circuits are essentially optimal
so
this is the result i mentioned today ago
two days ago
so there are one natural functions and
for some of them negations they speed up
computation and for some
they don't and i think a very
interesting direction
would be to try to formulate a more
general fear to explain
when such no monotone operations can
speed up the computation of monotone
functions
thank you
so can you um even simulate a monotone
threshold function
in monotone nc1 in like with monotone
formulas
yeah actually we spent a lot of time
working on this project
this was one of our original goals and
we couldn't establish this lower bound
so this can be seen as a weaker
separation that
is related to your question yeah
so i believe that for this function udn
the if you want polynomial size circuits
then you should have depth log n times
log d
that's my guess
another question so
this bound for the function decreases
with
as you have a larger d there is a
way to to yeah as i mentioned there is
an upper bound and
with larger d there is a certain
dividing concrete strategy to compute
the function
oh it's because we need the sum of the
numbers to prove lower bounds against
that d monotone majority circuit
so d grows with the lower boundary
banana probe
or for these functions
um yeah as far as i know you could have
uh
a single function that
or that actually i think like if it's a
monotone in nancy one then you can
somehow collapse some layers and this
end to the one over d is probably gonna
be present
maybe with a constant